uh so uh
today i will be talking about uh
learning our complete latent variable
models uh through tensor power method so
this is based on joint work with anima
anan kumar and uh majin
both from uclan and they are both here
so sorry for the long and complicated
title uh i guess i will start by
explaining the first part of the title
so what do i mean by learning our
complete latent variable model
so first just a very brief recap there
are many different kinds of learning
problems
the most popular one might be the
supervised learning problem
in this problem we are given data and
labels
for example we are given emails and we
want to tell whether they are spam or
not
the underlying assumption or belief is
that there should be some simple
classifier
in a certain class
and this classifier is able to
give correct labels to
at least most of the data
and the goal of learning is just to
learn this classifier
but in this talk the learning we are
going to focus on are
mostly unsupervised learning
so in the unsupervised learning model we
are given just data there are no labels
so underlying assumption or belief we
have is that these data should be
generated by some probabilistic model
this model may have some
unknown parameters
so the goal of learning is just
after observing all these data we want
to learn all the model parameters
so of course these two kinds of
learnings are also closely related and
you have heard from sanjiv's talk this
morning
in this talk i will focus on the
unsupervised learning
so many times we call a model a latent
variable model
and what that means is in the model we
have two kinds of variables
we have
first the latent variables which
anything latent
will be
this white
circle or
we'll have the color white
and we will also have the observed
variables
and they will always be represented by
blue things
so of course as the name suggests
we don't get to see the latent variables
we only observe the
observed variables
so the model will specify how the data
is generated
and usually for a latent variable models
this comes
from two steps
so in the first step the models specify
some simple distribution
that we can sample the latent variable
from the simple distribution
and then after we sampled this latent
variable
condition on the value of the latent
the model also specifies uh
what is the conditional distribution of
the observed variables conditioned on
the latent variable
so it's very possible that maybe both
the distribution of latent variables and
the conditional distribution both of
these are very simple distributions
but because we are just seeing the
observed variables it's possible the
marginal distribution is actually much
more complicated
and that is why we need to introduce
these latent variables
and in as in many other
unsupervised learning tasks the goal is
to given many samples of the observed
variables we want to learn the model
parameters so parameters both determine
what is the distribution for the latent
variables and also what is the
conditional distribution
for the observed variables
in many cases we might also want to
learn the latent
value of the latent variable after we
learn the model but that's
called the inference problem and we are
not going to talk about that in this
talk so let's look at some examples for
latent variable models
so the first example will be a mixture
of gaussians
so for mixture of gaussians we assume
the data actually come from the mixture
of k gaussians and for simplicity we
will in this talk we will assume they
are all spherical gaussians
and we know the covariance
of these
gaussians so the data will be just
points from these gaussians
in this case the model parameter will be
the mean saw and the weight of the
gaussians by weight of a gaussian i mean
what is the fraction of samples that
come from this particular gaussian
and we can view this as a latent
variable model because we can think of a
latent variable as a number
from 1 to k
and this number tells us which gaussian
are we going to sample from
so for each sample we first choose the
latent variable 1 to k according to the
weights
then we know which gaussian we want to
sample from
and after that we can sample observe
variable condition on that gaussian
so uh as you see the
distribution for a latent variable is
just a multinomial distribution it's
very simple the conditional distribution
is also just a gaussian which is also
very simple
but the marginal distribution on the
observed variables are a
mixture of gaussians which is much more
complicated than either one of them
well so
so now the problem is given samples of
these data points we want to learn the
means and the weights of the gaussians
so this is what i mean by learning a
latent variable model
and as you may recall in the title i
also have the word overcomplete
over complete might mean different
things for different models
but for this particular mixture of
gaussian's model by or complete i just
mean the number of gaussians should be
larger than the number of dimensions
they are in
for example in this case
we have three gaussians in a
two-dimensional space so this is one of
our complete setting
okay so uh another uh so mixture of
gaussians problem uh
actually we know how to
so in particular people use uh
expectation maximization algorithms to
learn mixture of gaussians
but in general we have no guarantee for
whether
em algorithms converge to the tube
parameters
we actually know how to learn these
sculptures in many cases but they are
usually using some complicated
algorithms
actually many of those algorithms are
developed by people in the audience
so another interesting model is called
the multiview model
in this model
it's a bit more abstract
depending on
so there are k classes of objects
and
we will have three independent views of
these objects for example you can think
of these three views as a
video audio and text that's describing
the same object
and the key assumption is these reviews
should really be independent conditioned
on this latent variable
so in this model the latent variables
are still a still a number from 1 to k
that specifies what is the class of the
object then after we have this latent
variable we just choose an object and we
have the three independent views of that
so observed variables are these maybe we
do audio inputs so
um
so this model is not uh only interesting
by
itself it's like you got three samples
of the same russian is that like what
right uh you you can think of it as a
i have a
hidden variable and then
these are three independent gaussians um
words it can be any other distribution
they don't have to be gaussian but in
the previous example it would be that
you get three independent regression
from the same gaussian so you you get
one choice between one and k then you
get three samples of it instead of only
one sample yes
that's one of the cases yes
yeah so this problem is not just
interesting by itself it's actually also
this structure that given a latent
variable condition on that we have
like at least three independent wheels
this kind of structure actually happens
a lot in latent variable models in fact
many other models including hidden
markov models or some community models
they can all be reduced to this
multiview model
and what are the model parameters in
this multiview model well
the model parameters will be the
conditional expectations
so
let's assume all these fields are
vectors in r to the d
then a condition on the hidden variable
having value i
there will be an expected vector for
this first field
and that vector will say it is equal to
a i
and we collect all these d dimensional
vectors a1 a2 to ak
as a matrix
so this a will be a d by k matrix
and its columns will be the conditional
expectations
of the first field
and similarly we will have the
conditional expectations of the second
view and third view so these are the
model parameters and also the mixing
weights are also part of the
model parameters
and again we also have our complete
multiview model
and by that we mean the number of
classes this number k
should be larger than the number of
dimensions
d here well in general they can have
different dimensions but in this talk
we'll focus on the simpler case where
they have the same dimension d
so uh
in this work we show that we can
actually learn these kind of models
actually some including some other
models
even when they are overcomplete
so for multiview or mixture of gaussians
model if the component means are chosen
at random mixing weights are close to
uniform then we show there's a simple
polynomial time algorithm
that learns all the component means with
accuracy k over d when number of
components is constant factor larger
than
number of dimensions
so let me parse this more slowly
so our algorithm works for our complete
models because we allow the number of
components
to be a constant factor larger than the
number of dimension d it can be any
constant but the running time will
depend on this constant c
also a drawback of our algorithm is we
do not really learn the true component
means
instead what we output
so these component means are actually
random unit vectors
so what we output will be a vector
that has l2 distance within square root
k over d
to the true r component
means
and finally we need to uh we say here we
assume the component means are random
vectors
but that's actually just for simplicity
we have a set of deterministic
conditions all those conditions are
satisfied with high probability for
random vectors
and here i just state random for
simplicity
so another part of our result says
if we have a
model when the variance is small so
this is uh
easier to think about in the mixture of
gaussian's case
so if the variance of each sample if the
variance of these gaussians
is bounded by some constant
then we have a polynomial time algorithm
that achieves the same accuracy
but in this case we can handle much more
or complete models we don't need a
number of components to be constant only
constant factor larger we can actually
handle uh as long as k is much smaller
than d to the 1.5
and notice that
in this given in this case the gaussians
are not really well separated
the distance between their means is a
constant but their variance is also a
constant so
they are separated but they are not
as well separated as some of the
previous algorithms required
and finally we proved very tight sample
complexity bonds for these algorithms
so we show in order to get accuracy
epsilon here
we would need to use a roughly order k
over epsilon square samples up to a
polylog factors
when the variance is bounded by a
constant
and this is tied up to polylog factors
because
uh let's still think about the mixture
of gaussian's case even if i tell you
for all the samples which gaussian it
came from
so how do in that case how do you
estimate the component means well you
will just take the average of all the
samples that come from the same
component
and even that procedure will have sample
complexity order k over epsilon squared
so in that sense
our algorithm has almost slide sample
complexity
so uh how can we hope to prove these
results well
because the title is
learning these variable latent variable
models through tensor power method
so i've shown you what are these latent
variable models
and tensor is some
high dimensional array so how do we
relate these models to tensors
well this is actually a very classical
method called the method of moments
so basically this tensor will be some
third order moment for these
latent variable models
and what do i mean by a third order
moment well let's uh
focus on this multiview model and start
from the much simpler first moment
so the first moment of this model is
just actually the expectations
so what is the expected
vector of the first view what is
expected second view and what is
expected third wheel
and of course we can
estimate those expectations
using the data so this mu vector is
something that we can observe
but it is also related to the model
parameters that we don't know for
example the
expectation of the first wheel
based on our model assumptions is going
to be equal to this matrix a
times
the weight vector w because remember the
ice column of a
is the conditional expectation
of a
when the hidden variable has value i
and this w i will be the probability
that this hidden variable has value i so
when you multiply a and w you you should
really get the
expectation of the first field
so similarly we can define a second
order
moment so these will be covariance
matrices
we can
compute say the expectation of the first
rule times the second real transpose so
that will be a matrix
and
again we can estimate this matrix from
the samples
and it is related to all these model
parameters
in this way
just believe me this is the right
formula
and similarly we can do the same thing
for b and c or a and c
we don't do it for a because
the covariance matrix for a is not
really determined by the model
assumptions
and
we also need the third order moment
which now is not a vector or a matrix it
has to be represented by a d by d by d
tensor
and
the i1 i2 i3's component of this tensor
will be the expectation of the i1 entry
in the first wheel
the i2's entry in the second wheel times
the i3's entry in the third wheel
and
if you are familiar with tensor product
then
this tensor is really the expectation of
the tensor product of
a b and c of the three wheels
from now on for simplicity i will just
drop the weights and assume all the
weights are one
that case
this third order moment the tensor
will really be equal to the sum from i
from 1 to k
a i tensor bi tensor ci because these a
i b i c i's
conditional expectations for these three
views
so then
so method of moments is actually a
very classical uh
two in statistics it's introduced by uh
person in
1894 so it's really old
so generally there are two steps when we
want to apply method of moments
so the first
step given these samples of these data
we will estimate
these lower order moments
and then given these moments
we would like to find a set of model
parameters
that's consistent with observed moments
because that all these moments are
closely related to the model parameter
in fact in our case there will be
polynomials in the model parameters
so hopefully if we could solve that
system of polynomial equations
it will tell us what is the set of model
parameters
that are consistent with the moments
before applying this method of moments
there are things that we need to worry
about so the first thing we need to
worry about is an identifiability
problem
so given all these moments
this expectations
is there a unique set of model
parameters
that generates a model that agrees with
all these moments
if the solution to that problem is not
even unique then we cannot hope to
learn the model parameters using just
these moments
in fact
that's the reason why we need to use
this tensor
because we can show if you just have the
first order the means and the second
order covariances
it is not good enough to
learn all the parameters there can be
many different models
that generates the same first and second
order moment
but the identifiability problem
the solution will be unique once we have
the tensor
and then suppose the solution is unique
the next question we want to ask
is
algorithmic so how do we find the model
parameters if the solution is unique
this is this could be really hard in
general because
in general it's trying to solve some
system of polynomial equations and of
course that is hard
but
the hope here is these moments will have
some very nice
structures and we can use that
to
design efficient algorithms
and finally if we have an algorithm
a problem that's very important in
practice is what is the sample
complexity of this algorithm
because in practice we can estimate all
these moments but we don't have
infinitely many samples
uh
the moments we get are going to only
going to be accurate up to some um
epsilon arrow
so uh how many samples do we need until
these moments are accurate enough
for the algorithm to recover
a reasonable set of parameters so that
is also something that's really
important when we want to apply
methodology moments
so for now let's first focus on the
first two parts uh identifiability and
algorithm
only towards the end i will talk briefly
about sample complexity
so in fact
for
this particular mixer
for this particular multiview model
this identifiability and algorithm
problem is
quite well studied
basically if we have the third order
tensor
in order to get the model parameters we
would want to write this tensor
as the sum of k
rank 1 components
so this inner product tensor product of
aibi and ci
will be a rank one tensor
and this decomposition will be trying to
decompose
a tensor as some of rank one tensors
this is usually called the cp
decomposition
in the related literatures and
the smallest case that you can do this
decomposition is usually one definition
of tensor rank
so people have been studying the cpd
composition since 1970s
and
there are many results known
so for example for identifiability when
does this tensor have a unique
low rank decomposition
well
this solution is unique whenever
2k is smaller than 3d minus 2
when these components are in general
positions
will not define that but
so even when this tensor is over
complete when number of components k
is larger than the dimension d
in many cases this tensor decomposition
is still unique
and that's a famous result by kruskal
we can get much stronger results for
random components when these components
a i v i c i's are really random random
unit vectors
this tensor decomposition is really
unique when k is much smaller than d to
the 1.5
so in general we can even hope to solve
this problem in the more
our complete setting
but unfortunately finding
this best run k decomposition is np hard
in general
even for third order tensors and this is
and
in fact so is many other problems
related to tensors
this is a result by healer and limb
uh in the algorithmic side
we for a long time we only know how to
solve this problem in the under complete
case
by here by under complete i mean the
number of component k should be at most
number of dimension d for all these
components
so there are many algorithms for that
for example you can do simultaneous
diagonalization which appeared
even early 70s
but in practice people often use an
algorithm called tensor power method
which is an analog of matrix power
method that's used to find the top
singular vectors of matrices
so what does tensor power method do
uh it actually is an algorithm that's
designed to find tensor decomposition in
the orthogonal case
uh i'll do it
oh yes uh so cp
is an abbreviation
that's for two other abbreviations so c
stands for this candy comp
and p is from paraffect uh
and both these i don't know what are
those things
yes so and i think those two names come
from these two papers independently
and they are around the same time so
that's why it's called cp compositions
yeah so a tensor power method
as i said is analog to matrix power
method and it works in the orthogonal
case
by osaka i mean uh these components uh
aibi ci are orthogonal uh to be more
precise i i don't mean that ai should be
also known to bi i mean
uh a is should be also known to ajs bi
should be also known to bj's but there's
no constraint on aibi and cis
so you don't know it's in the long run
situation
uh yes so because they are in
all orthogonal and we cannot have more
than d orthogonal vectors this has to be
in the under complete or low rank case
so this algorithm how does it work well
it first gets vectors
what you can randomly pick vectors a hat
and b hat
and then you do this
tensor power update which i'm not going
to define what this means
but think of it as i have a vector i can
if i have a matrix i can left multiply
this vector by a matrix
and that will give me a new vector
a similar thing is true for tensors
except because tensor is a d by d by d
object i need to multiply by two vectors
to get a new vector
and this is something we can compute but
it's actually also closely related to
this tensor decomposition
that we don't really know
so
this is really equal to that and let's
come to that later
so so now we compute this vector c hat
once we get c hat we will fix c hat and
b hat and try to update this vector a
hat
so we will compute a hat as
the tensor applied to the vector b hat
and c hat
and similarly uh we will fix that we
will then fix a hat and c hand and
compute a new vector b hat so we do all
these three steps iteratively until they
converge
so it's not hard to see that
if a hat b hat c hat are equal to sum of
the components a i b i and c i
that is actually a stable point of this
iteration because i look at this formula
the a i's are orthogonal so essentially
if a hat is equal to some ai then the
sum really has only one nonzero term and
that non-zero term will give me ci so a
ib ici should really just be a stable
point of this kind of updates
fixed point not stable exports you're
not saying that if i start nearby
yeah so so what i explained only proof
that there are fixed points they are in
fact stable points
and we can show that
we can in fact show that these are the
only stable points
there are
other fixed points but these are really
the only stable ones
and we can show if you start randomly it
usually converges in log d steps
if you have the exact answer and that's
known uh
that's known quite uh early
so in the work with uh anima and
daniel charm and martins we show that
this kind of algorithm works even under
noise so if even if we are not given the
exact tensor we get something that's
close this algorithm can still work
but all these analysis are really in the
orthogonal case
and in general for under complete case
we can do some
linear transformation to reduce them to
the oxygen case
but in the over complete case this is
not really possible because as
you pointed out uh
in
d dimensions we cannot have more than
the other known vectors
so then what we know about uh over
complete tensor decompositions
well only recently we started to know
algorithms were that can briefly
decompose
over complete tensors
for example last year there are a couple
of results that show how to decompose
say a general tensor of rank order d
squared so when k is order d squared
using a fifth order tensor
so moses character is going to talk
partly about this result in his thursday
talk so if you are interested go to that
a similar result is by
santosh and others so many of the
authors are in the audience
so
also
if we
have the exact tensor actually it's
known that we can decompose a
tensor in general position
of rank order d square using just fourth
order tensor so we don't really need to
go to the fifth order
but both uh
so all these algorithms say
so
so these algorithms have sample
complexity bonds as this algorithm we
don't know
but all these algorithms require
also they require polynomially many
samples it is a large polynomial
depending on the data
and also sometimes we don't really want
to use fourth and fifth order tensor not
just because uh
using higher order tensor you would
require uh more computation
but uh naively
if you have the multiview model if you
only have three views
then
we can only construct a third order
tensor
in order to get a fifth order tensor we
really need to have five independent
views and that is sometimes hard to
catch
yes
yes you need to normalize after all
steps sorry i just omitted that for
simplicity
yeah so
so what happens in practice well in
practice
people really use these algorithms
people often use alternating least
squares which i'll explain later
were some variant of power method
and they don't run these algorithms on
higher order tensor because running them
on third order tensor is already quite
expensive
so we only have proof that says power
method works for under complete case
but actually it works reasonably well in
practice even when we have over complete
tensors
well alternating these scores even work
better in that case
and also in berkeley
we observe that these algorithms do not
need too many samples
they do not need some huge polynomial
depending
on the dimension or the
number of components
so as you see there is
still a large gap between what's known
in theory and what we observe in
practice
and that is
the main motivation of our work
so what is our results when we restate
them in the tensor decomposition
language
well in tensor decomposition language
our results show that
if there is a run k tensor that looks
like this
recall this tensor
is what we observe if we compute the
expectation of the tensor product of the
three views
so if these components uh aibi cis are
random unit vectors
and when the number of components is
just a constant times larger than the
dimension d
then there's a polynomial time algorithm
that finds all these components up to
accuracy over square root k over d
and in addition if we don't just have
this tensor in instead of this tensor we
also have
very good initialization vectors in the
sense that we have vectors that are
constant close to a i b i and c i
we can refine these
approximate versions of a b and c
to accuracy order square k over d
and this works for
the more over complete setting
and finally uh
for the sample complexity bond it will
eventually follow from the fact that
using order k over epsilon square
samples
we can estimate this particular tensor t
with accuracy epsilon in
a tensor spectral norm which i will
define later
is there some
some point at which if you have a
you can refine your estimate to be
arbitrarily accurate
uh yeah so that's a very nice question
we
now know the answer should be yes
but uh seen some upcoming work that i'm
not able to talk about today
the difficulty is that if the vectors
are random then they're not quite
orthogonal
and so the power method naively gives
you
so yes so all these uh statements are
done using power method but if you
continue to use power method there's no
way that you can go beyond this accuracy
so what we actually need to do is
after we get these k over d close
vectors we need to use some other
algorithm in order for them to
converge to the true components
uh but i'm not going to talk about that
so i'm a little confused how does the
power method
array
is bigger than b
right so uh
so you just try to find all of them uh
so basically so
let's look at uh this case suppose we
have these very nice initialization
vectors
then given these initialization vectors
we can try to run the power method
and we can show it will converge to
these vectors up to accuracy root k or d
if we have k
groups of such initialization vectors we
can find all these k components up to
the same accuracy
so as i said in practice people often
use alternating least squares instead of
power method
so alternating these squares is this
algorithm that given the tensor t it
first randomly gets
two parts of the components a and b so
here a and b are d by k matrices
and then it tries to minimize our d by k
matrices c
such that this tensor t minus
this uh run k tensor the problem is norm
is minimized
notice that uh what's inside is a linear
function on this matrix ci and what we
are optimizing is a
from venice norm squared so this is
really a least squares problem so we can
find these optimal ci's efficiently
and then after we find the cis we again
fix cr c and b and optimize our a
then we fix a and c and optimize our b
and we alternate between all these steps
that's why it is called alternating lead
squares
so this procedure the problem is trying
to optimize this highly non-convex
problem
if you look at this
optimizing over a b and c
then this is a really highly non-convex
problem even if we just have a and b
it's already non-convex
and essentially we don't know any
convergence results unless these ai bi
and ci's are like universe polynomially
close to the true components
and in fact much closer than what we
guarantee the square root k already
so
and in fact if we just assume our
nice initialization vectors that are
column wise only say a constant point
one close
to the true component
then when you are solving this
least squares problem for the matrix c
well the usual way to do that you need
to do a matrix inversion
that matrix under just this assumption
may not even have a inverse it might not
be invertible
so even if it's invertible it can be it
can have very bad condition number and
in that case the algorithm is very
unstable
so
sometimes in order to overcome these
problems people instead use alternating
rank 1 update
so here the idea is i will not try to
find
the run k decomposition in one shot
instead i will try to find a rank 1
approximation to the tensor and
hopefully this rank 1 approximation will
be close to one of the components
so basically uh
given this tensor t we
guess
initially a hat and b hat
and we minimize the difference between t
and this rank one component so in a
sense this is
trying to find the best rank one
approximation of the tensor but of
course it's
if we optimize over all a b and c it's
still not complex
and then uh similar to all the previous
algorithms this algorithm then alternate
between finding a hat and b-hat
and see how
the algorithm converges
and it turns out this alternating rank 1
update is really equivalent to power
method
the c hat that uh optimize uh this
function
is really well not it's not necessarily
equal it's proportional to the tensor
applied to a hat and b hat
yeah and we had the same expression as
we had before
um
so that's why i say people often also
use power method in practice
so although this function is still
knowledge convex uh
at least we don't need to solve the
u-conditioned least squares problem
so it's uh often more stable than
alternating these squares and we can
hope to analyze uh this updating rule
so when you're saying this is equivalent
these are your phenomenal assumptions no
this is under no assumption uh as long
as your tensor
it's really under no assumption uh this
optimize
the optimal c
is really uh equal to the tensor applied
to this
because
well i take some linear algebra to see
that you can expand this um
it's the best rank one update right
that's what
power method is
yeah it's like if i already have this
direction a hat and b hat what is the
most correlated direction to the tensor
and that is actually given by this
tensor analogy
no we don't need uh so so so so this
fact does not uh require uh
orthogonality so the c hat is
proportional to t applied to this
uh it's just uh
and i understand but for this method to
work that you can update oh yes so so
that's what we are trying to show so
before we show that for this algorithm
to converge to the optimal solution
you need oscillatory but now we are
going to say even though these are not
orthogonal it still kind of works in the
sense that it converges to something
that's
very close to one of the components
they are merely random is it easier to
see that one of the vectors one of the
decomposition terms is actually the best
rank one approximation
uh
right so
so that actually takes some proof and
especially when k is very large when k
is like d to the 1.5
and
yes
and the reason is really this t of a hat
b hat c hat is uh some objective
function and that is
maximized when you are close to one of
the components
so that's something that you need to
mean essentially we need conditions like
that these random vectors the you know
spectral norm of the tensor is
controlled the spectral norm of the
matrices are controlled so all these
conditions
lead to the balance
yeah so um how can we hope to analyze uh
this power method iteration in the
long orthogonal case
well the intuition is
hopefully when these vectors a hat and b
hat
are close to the so one of the
components a i and bi
then this tensor applied to a hat and b
hat
hopefully it is equal to
where it's proportional
to c i plus noise and then we will show
the noise is small
and
why do we believe that's true well we
can write this tensor applied to a hat
and b hat
as the sum of two terms
so the first term only has to do with
this particular component i
and as we assumed these inner products
are like larger than 0.9 so this is
really
a large constant times a vector c i
and then uh in the remaining terms we
have sum of
or all the other components
uh something like that
so this will be the noise term
and we can hope the noise term is small
because uh remember these ar aj bjcjs
are
random vectors
so for a vector a hat is really hard for
it to be correlated to have large inner
product
with all of these random vectors that's
not possible
and also for b it's again very hard for
it to have a large inner product with
all of them
so these coefficients should be somewhat
small and also these cj's are random
vectors so hopefully they will not align
with each other
and there might be some cancellations
going on
so that's intuitively why we believe
this noise in the noise term should be
small
and in order to prove that we need to
do some work
and in the end
we are going to be
able to prove this key lemma
that says if my initial vectors a hat
and b hat
are delta close to a i and b i and this
delta is small enough
then the c hat found by the algorithm
what basically t hat applied to a hat
and b hat
and after normalization it is less than
2 delta squared
order k over d to the 1.5 times delta
times order k over d over root k already
close to c i
and this is very good because the
delta is small so 2 delta squared is
much smaller than delta over 2 say
this guy
by our assumption is also very small so
this is also contracting
it's just this term that does not become
smaller as we take more iterations
so basically this lemma implies as long
as delta is much larger than square root
k over d
the ci we found as we find will be a
much closer to sorry the c hat we find
will be much closer to ci than either of
a hat and b hat
and when we iterate over this kind of
update
we can hope the algorithm to converge in
a log number of iterations
and when it converges all these vectors
a hat b hat and c hat will be order
square root k over d
close to this component a i b i and c i
so now the the only problem we need to
solve is how how do we really get uh
these very nice initialization vectors
how do we get a handle on b hat that's
constant closed
to these components a i and bi
well there are many cases for this
so in the low noise case recall that
this is the case when
say for a mixture of gaussians the
variance of gaussian is a small constant
if it's a small constant then we can
just use the samples themselves
and these samples themselves are very
close to
the mean of the samples
if this variance is slightly larger we
can try to do average over a constant
number of samples so that's also in
polynomial time
so in the low noise case it's really
simple we just use the samples
uh so there are there's actually a
intermediate case which we call the semi
supervised setting
in this setting we uh
are actually given the latent variables
for some of the samples
yeah so
in that case for example for mixture of
gaussian we know some samples come from
the same distribution
so it comes from the same gaussian then
we can just take the
sample mean of those samples
and hopefully that will be close enough
to the component mean
and finally what do we do for the
unsupervised case
in this case we can hope to do singular
value decomposition
over a random slice of this tensor so
this tensor applied to a random vector u
so this actually gives us a matrix
so i don't have time to explain why this
works but
for integration is if we pick a random
vector u
with some inverse polynomial probability
it will have very large inner product
with one of these components cis
and have
like smaller inner products
with all the other ci's
which means
this matrix we get will really have a
very large
singular vector that's close to
the sea ice using the
perturbation bonds on matrix singular
values
and we can use that bond to get a good
initialization pair a
that's close to ai and bi
uh so finally in the last uh
five minutes i'll
talk about uh briefly about this
oh it's sorry
oh oh okay uh sorry so so in for the
sample complex t we can prove that um
with n samples the estimated tensor is
root k over n close and because the
final accuracy is proportional to the
spectral norm we need k over epsilon
square samples
and tensor spectral norm is defined to
be a tensor applied as the maximum over
the unit vectors uv and w
tensor applied to these unit vectors
similar to matrix spectral norm but i
like that it's mp hard to compute
uh it's not easy to prove tight sample
complexity bonds for tensors because
the usual way of doing that is we can
think of a d by d by d tensor as a d by
d square matrix and maybe we can bound
the matrix spectral norm
of that matrix and that's always larger
than the tensor spectral norm
but this approach cannot work in here
because the matrix spectral norm in this
case is actually indeed larger than the
tensor spectronorm
and
another idea is you to use epson nets
but that also does not work as there are
too many vectors
so in our work we use some more refined
epsilon net arguments we distinguish
between uncorrelated vectors and
correlated vectors
and are
and then using this trade-off we will be
able to get a tight sample complexity
bonds
so in conclusion we show that there's a
tensor decomposition algorithm that
works on overcomplete third order tensor
has applications in learning latent
variable models and have time sample
complexity bonds
there are many open problems so first we
want to remove the arrow root k over d
which we now know how to do but it's in
upcoming paper
so also we want to do a tensor
decomposition for
this k to the k is equal to d to the 1.5
without using good initial vectors
so this is somewhere when sum of squares
could
actually be useful and we are thinking
about that
and finally what can we say about
tensors that do not have random
components but have
like competency in general position
thanks and sorry for going over time